romance cryptocurrency and investment
scams are skyrocketing highly
sophisticated Highly Educated people as
well as large corporations are
increasingly being scammed Kirsten Joyce
takes a closer look at how you can avoid
becoming the next romance scam victim it
feels real 68 year old Yvonne Harland
had nearly given up on dating when
friends suggested she tried Tinder
almost immediately a man reached out
you're the most beautiful woman I've
ever seen she was intoxicated with the
attention they began communicating
through text then phone calls they would
call me seven o'clock in the morning and
11 o'clock at night and you know it's
it's spring someone is
calling you regularly in Texas like that
you sort of begin to anticipate then but
the first red flag came when he canceled
their in-person meeting he had an excuse
and a few weeks later he asked her to
help sell his father's European estate
and I thought well that's a real switch
you know usually they're asking for
money they don't want you to receive
money
and I did some research and come to find
out that is money laundering and I could
be subject to criminal penalties she
said no about a month later after he
professed his love for her she didn't
hear from him for two days I wrote to
him and I said is everything okay and he
goes no there was an explosion at my
work site and all the computers were
destroyed and this machine fell on me
and I broke my leg and
he sent me a picture of him in the
hospital with a hospital he urged her to
help him by selling his computers and
that's when she called it off I blocked
and deleted all of his texts and
everything I was so angry and upset I
didn't think I was lonely and desperate
but I've been working from home for two
years maybe I was it's incredible the
amount of victims that feel like they're
in a real relationship David mcclellan's
company social catfish has been tracking
these scamming Trends seriously for the
past five years using data from the
FBI's internet crime complaint center
and the FTC along with a poll of more
than 3 000 romance scam victims he found
that unlike other scams that happened
quickly romance scams last on average
six to nine months and 75 percent of
romance scam victims have some form of
college education they're breeding you
to become the person they want you to be
they're isolating you from friends and
family they're building this
relationship and this Persona that
they've they've given you more than a
third of romance scams originate on
social media or scammers create fake
profiles to engage people are victimized
all over the internet you know on you
know social media is extremely popular
you know Instagram Facebook Tick Tock
are still the top social networks that
we've seen we've seen a lot of emerging
apps so any app that you can talk to
somebody online so like a game like
words with friends where you can chat
back and forth with strangers who are
seeing scammers Target those McClellan
says keep your accounts private be
cautious of strangers who randomly
message you don't click on any links
don't accept or send any money in the
end it wasn't cash but Pride that Yvonne
lost you've gambled and you lost and you
you know you you've been made a fool of
and you really kind of deserve that
because I you know all along the way I
knew red flags
so Yvonne now uses social catfish it's
an online investigation service that
verifies information about the person
you've met online